9 I am a UPS guy knocks on our door and
in his hands is a giant hand carp
handling whatever you want to call with
these two gigantic crates from origin
feces inside these crates are two super
powered computers which we will now
attempt to open with hammers and
crowbars because they do not mess around
now I have really nice crates boxes
fuses prize what's it important
oh there's actual instructions buried
within the box hold on oh you open it
from the side okay and move the screws
already oh my god there's more
instructions oh my god it's another box
box of accessories
swag swag more swag oh if all things go
correctly though these guys we should be
able to plug them in hook them up and it
should be working right off the bat
they're pre overclocked too so no
messing with the settings just plug them
in turn them on get into work
those are you guys so much node and LAN
party you may recognize its cases you
project matter with Forge and brand
appears they've looked us all up with
the computer over there awesome gaming
computers and now they've hooked us up
with some awesome workstations these
things have Titans and then they have
incredibly nice CPUs overclock liquid
cooling it's gonna be some good stuff so
we're gonna get these up and running
we're gonna test them out we're going to
benchmark these suckers because every
time I get a new computer we always run
one thing and that's super Pi what's
super ports super pilot super Buy is a
program that calculates digits of pi and
as fast as we can calculate digits is a
great way to measure computer
success failed so as you can see the new
origin computer is easily beating some
of our old computers here we're actually
gonna make a second video following up
to join you guys not only in what areas
is the computer faster but also telling
you why it's faster and what you should
look for in a new computer if you are
also putting together a nice video
editing rig so stay tuned and look
forward to that second video we're gonna
really go in-depth as to what makes
these machines faster and what you can
look for till then thanks for watching
guys
so once again huge thanks to Origin PC
for hooking us up with these awesome
workstations we have a ton of videos
coming out this fall that we're gonna
need this kind of horsepower for and I
think these are the perfect computers to
do the job eat horse EE horsepower Eve
or psa's so if you guys are interested
in acquiring a PC of yourself you guys
should check out their website they have
a bunch of really cool stuff on there
including ones like these